avant la communication politique c'était
ça j'aurai un président qui informerait
et aujourd'hui c'est ça alors je vous
lance un défi
et si vous avez 10 millions de vues en
engagement vous m'étonnez à l'elysée la
seule différence c'est le biais de cette
communication
quand auparavant les partis au
gouvernement aux prêts pour un spot télé
aujourd'hui ils s'offrent une place sur
les écrans portables des jeunes et je
leur ai dit et je le répète ce live
n'est pas sponsorisé you berloty mme
shea
c'est à se demander qui est influenceurs
et qui est politique
pourquoi les politiques mises autant sur
les influences or depuis peu et dans
quel but
et pourquoi les influenceurs accepte de
diffuser des messages politiques et même
titre qu'un placement de produit
éléments de réponse dans facture
[Musique]
reprenons un influenceur d'après le
robert c'est une personne qui
influencent l'opinion la consommation
par son audience sur les réseaux sociaux
mais quand on pense aux influenceurs qui
nous vendait des machines abdou des
produits amincissants ou des produits de
beauté à la manière d'un télé achat les
choses ont bien changé ils ne sont plus
de simples vecteur d'achat mais des
leaders d'opinion j'ai été contacté
ainsi que d'autres influences heures il
ya quelques semaines de ça pour aller à
la rencontre du porte-parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent afin de lui
poser toutes les questions que vous vous
posiez aujourd'hui influenceurs rime
souvent avec partenariat monétiser sont
autorisés publicité mais ça consiste en
quoi concrètement
pour faire simple les marques contact en
influence heures pour promouvoir un
produit la marque en elle-même -
discours ensuite le créateur de contenus
prépare une vidéo ou une photo grâce à
sur brive qui est donc posté sur les
différents réseaux sociaux de l'influent
soeur
sauf qu'aujourd'hui ce ne sont plus
seulement les marques qui démarche les
personnalités publiques 2.0 c'est aussi
les personnalités politiques et même le
gouvernement avec sa campagne tenir
ensemble qui avait fait le buzz
d'après un membre du cabinet d'emmanuel
mâcon que nous avons pu contacter le
fait d'utiliser des influenceurs c'est
assez français parce que dans l'est dans
les autres pays on a plutôt tendance à
voir des politiques s'emparent et
franchement des réseaux sociaux et le
faire eux mêmes en france on est habitué
à parler aux gens à travers la presse
très peu en direct donc bizarrement on
va garder cette habitude sur les réseaux
sociaux donc si un tout petit peu plus
inquiétant c'est ce besoin d'aller
chercher des influenceurs plutôt que de
se dire je vais plonger dans la réalité
des réseaux
je vais essayer de comprendre comment ça
marche je le faire moi même ce serait
tellement plus fort après cette même
personne travaillant pour la
communication de l'elysée au
gouvernement cherche à atteindre un
public qui ne l'est plus la presse et
les médias et qui s'informent uniquement
via les réseaux sociaux et c'est donc
dans cette démarche le porte parole du
gouvernement mme gabriela talent a lancé
le 24 février la première édition de son
émission appelée sans filtre diffusé sur
twitter avec des invités lève question
impôts c'est une très bonne chose après
la question que je me pose c'est
pourquoi des influenceurs avec gabriella
talent autant pour le chef de l'état
dont on a fait un jupiter inaccessible
ça peut paraître bien d'avoir des gens
qui servent d'intermédiaires mais pour
gabriela talent qui a 30 ans qui est
l'âge des gens qui sont en gros sur
twitch pourquoi avoir besoin d
appréhension à côté de lui pourquoi ne
pas y aller tout seul
pourquoi ne pas devenir finalement lui
même en a fait en sommes là je trouve
que c'est une très belle initiative
c'est un peu osé de la part du
gouvernement est un peu risqué et je
trouve que ça a été bien fait en fait ça
permet tout simplement aux jeunes de
poser des questions les questions qu'ils
ont et c'est meilleur canal pour aller
les toucher pour 2020 année de la
pandémie de comédie 19 40 % des
créateurs de contenu aurait fait un
partenariat d'intérêt public
d'après une étude réalisée par reach
pour florence dupont les partenariats
avec le gouvernement n'ont pas été
rémunérés
alors quel est l'intérêt pour les
influenceurs à aller sur ce terrain
glissant
c'est simple ils ont deux choses à green
et la première c'est que je pense qu'ils
sont souvent ravis de pouvoir contribuer
à quelque chose de positif quand il
travaille avec une ong quand ce travail
est le gouvernement ou quand même sans
partenariat est aussi parfois dans
certains cas quand c'est un gros projet
ça leur sert en termes de communication
un mc fly est clair les taux avant ça on
voit bien que tous les médias en parlent
donc
c'est lorsque aussi bonne pub ils sont
ravis c'est un peu une pierre degoul et
l'intérêt de tous politiques à vouloir
accéder à cette tranche de population
plus facile d'accès et bien moins
coûteuse qu'une campagne de
communication traditionnels et
d'ailleurs il ya 92 % des consommateurs
qui font davantage confiance à la
recommandation d'un influenceurs qu'est
la publicité classique
ça démontre le pouvoir de l' influence
bad influence sur les gens crainte de
répercussions sur notre mode de
consommation et de vivre en fait les
internautes ont donc plus confiance aux
influenceurs sauf quand cette
communication émane du gouvernement
un de ces ratés a eu lieu pour sa
campagne autour du service national
universel où est sa nuit destinée aux 15
et 7 en gage à ouvrir les mains trop
trop stylé regardez ça c'est du comics a
présidé mardi d'une société qui donne
énormément pour nous donc maintenant
c'est à nous de donner en retour en
incarnant les valeurs du pays comme il
le faut cette campagne avait été
vivement critiquée sur les réseaux
sociaux allant même jusqu'à dénoncer une
propagande du gouvernement
plus récemment ce n'est pas lui à ses
nus qui a été mise en lumière mais
l'application des gestes barrières
emmanuel macron a lancé un défi ou
youtuber mcfly et carlito leur demandant
de faire une vidéo toute simple pour
rappeler les gestes barrière
c'est la vidéo venait à atteindre les 10
millions de vu qu'ils ont largement
dépassé et youtube heures seraient
invités à l'elysée
ils organiseront un concours d'anecdotes
avec président ce qui est clairement du
jamais vu mc fly et carlito déjà sur les
influenceurs stars du moment et déjà
depuis un moment
ils ont quand même plus de six millions
d'abonnés et c'est une chaîne de
divertissement il faut écrire les jeunes
et parle de plein de choses c'est très
intelligent pour moi de participer à un
projet qu'on m'explique un lit tôt et le
gouvernement
d'autant plus que je trouve que c'est
plutôt bien fait parce que le dispositif
en tout cas en tant qu'agence d'
influence que dire qu'il est bien ficelé
l'affluence or comme la flamme à creil
carlito peuvent se dire ah politique
quand ils font un clip avec un candidat
à une élection et font de la politique
c'est tout le problème des affluences
heures c'est qu'au fond on va aller
chercher précisément parce qu'ils n'ont
pas de base politique les gens plus
confiance en eux quand un homme
politique ils ont plus confiance on ne
quant aux médias parce que ce sont des
gens a priori sympa qui nous font rire
qui nous détendre qui nous divertissent
donc on se méfie pas
c'est pour ça qu'on va les chercher mais
à partir du moment où on peut y rentrer
là dedans ils font de la politique
suite à cette campagne à double
tranchant quelles sont les critiques à
attendre tu as beau être en réel tout
comme mais la question à savoir si la
démarche sera accepté par le public
si le pari sera finalement réussi au
risque d'être taxé de propagande comme
le pc new il ya peut-être des personnes
probablement plus âgées qui vont j'en
sais rien c'est ridicule ou ce n'est pas
approprié
n'empêche que s'il ya plein de jeunes
qui apprennent des nouvelles choses et
qu'ils sont plus impliqués
dans la crise grâce à ça bah ouais
l'objectif est atteint
c'est pas de la propagande si le contrat
est clair encore une fois c'est un
affluent sur 10 moi j'aime bien manier
le maquereau je pense qu'il devrait être
élu président c'est clair il n'y a pas
de propagande c'est la communication la
droite faire ce qu'il veut si par contre
c'est cacher c'est là où on dans la
propagande et si l'influencé
il ya une règle dans la politique
française c'est que les politiques
s'intéressent aux réseaux sociaux
le temps de l'élection une fois qu'ils
soient élus en général
pour eux c'est sale c'est dangereux
c'est pas bien c'est là où les humeurs
française s'exprime donc hiziv en plus
ils diraient qu'ils arrêtent de le faire
s'il ya des évolutions sociétaires la
presse contre lesquelles on peut pas
grand chose là pour l'instant on est à
mi chemin
le président veut bien aller sur les
réseaux sociaux pour se faire réélire
mais c'est tout et puis avec matelas et
carlito quoi c'est ce film good possède
la publicité c'est vous et vous
[Musique]